okay hello everyone
welcome to
uh another software design review
meeting
language completeness and consistency
for wolverine language
um this is my third live stream today
wow just finished one about history of
science and technology all right this is
a different topic we are building a
little bit of the future here
okay
first topic
symbols for font variation
okay
sorry i was muted uh
yes right so there is a suggestion which
came from
somewhere i don't know where uh actually
uh
right so right there are various
right so we have things like underlying
and bold for the sort of universal most
common
uh
font variations right now there are an
infinite number of font variations some
of which only make sense for certain
characters in certain fonts so it's not
like we're going to
have a symbol for every font variation
um well i mean
yeah right what why aren't we doing
i mean in addition to this you know the
fact that we do style of
of uh something comma bold
rather than bold of the thing
i mean i guess it's because it's a style
specification
yes
um
so
i mean i mean bold of the thing actually
does work in the context of graphics
in graphics
uh sorry excuse me uh sorry if you uh so
bold couldn't work as a directive
um
in graphics
right yeah it doesn't work as a head it
works as a directive
just because it's like style
yes
right but that's not yeah it never works
right right right just just like you can
do blue comma disk to get a blue disk
you can in graphics you can do bold
comma text to get
some bolded text in your graphics but
it's never used as a head and i
does it work if you say graphics of um
let's just do this
text zero zip no text hello zero zero
okay fine now i say style
yes yes of course i would
yes okay that's obvious right yes of
course it works
okay so if i say here
font variation
arrow
oh boy these are kind of
why does it bother with oh i see strike
through
because the factor is actually necessary
because we don't have a symbol for that
no no no i realize i realize but i mean
so
okay
so then
so the proposal here is to more
mainstream a bunch of these font
variations i think that sounds like a
great idea
which ones are there that are fairly
common
i mean
yeah go ahead i think those three are
the ones that are fairly
universal i mean i think do we have
jeremy here by any chance
uh
jeremy d i don't think so
somebody see if we could find him
yeah i can do that
thanks
um
i think there are other ones
aren't there i mean what other
there's uh
well i mean you can see the full list
and the option inspector uh the
principal issue is that some of them are
not universally implemented on all
platforms
and in fact
it's possible actually there might be
some today that aren't implemented on
any platform it's
uh
you know
operating systems have changed over time
and i don't remember exactly what the
compatibility matrix is
right don't we
underline
yeah underline wasn't underlined yes we
do yeah right so we already have
underlying i didn't know that
when did we introduce that with a d
underlined as a style yeah
wait a minute as a style
but i mean
so if i say hello
comma underlined
i didn't know that how long have we had
that
20 30 years
you cannot be serious
a very long time i i will be honest i
didn't know it either but i know why i
don't know it because i never underline
anything
all right so v6 so 15.
it almost certainly added at the same
time that bold and plain and italic were
added
it's sort of shocking that i didn't know
that
i just want to make another comment that
is not related to this but is is related
to some to what i just had to do here
so
i would like us so take a function like
this okay i want to take all of those
things and i want to try all those
possibilities on some boolean expression
okay
how the heck do i get that list
other than by scraping it from this page
which is absurd
i mean
there was some you know you've mentioned
this before and it's gone to brian and
you know
i guess brian is busy with other things
so uh
right but we don't
well
what i think we should do
is i mean we've talked about having this
general informational thingy dingy
but
you know i think we should just have
something on the data repository and it
should just say yes that's exactly what
you said last time oh good well at least
i'm being consistent yes like i said
they're right there
we scrape these things as part of the
build process and we stick them in the
data repository and we
advertise some way to extract it
and but you know right we need somebody
if we're going to do this we need
somebody from the who understands the
doc build system to do this right i'm
not going to sit down and no i realize
right so okay so can we i i i i hesitate
to say this but uh but one could imagine
uh
you know a stronger notion of reflection
where instead of having to keep separate
databases about this that this would be
somehow you know this capability would
somehow be more deeply integrated into
the language
yes
but perhaps involved from language later
um
but the question is still how does it
get populated right and so so at least
if i understood john's point correctly
so the idea would be to introduce
additional programming conventions in
order to make these programmatically
access accessible
because because there has to be
something in the code that's checking
against a list and issuing a message if
you don't specify one of these forms
right and so
therefore
uh there could be some way of
publicizing that list
right although that list could be in c
code and also support all sorts right
but undocumented for whatever reason
right but i'd like to generalize that
because john has long been pushing for
this asset you know this way of of
factoring out assets
of of things right yes yes which i'm
hoping that we'll start discussing for
real sometime in the next uh
several months yes okay by the way is
that on the project list on the global
project list the asset thing i think so
but i'm not for sure why don't we check
um
and and also
uh
can we make sure that this point about
um
um
[Music]
sort of data resources from capabilities
capabilities lists
is probably what we might call this
thing capabilities lists might be a nice
name
um capability data or something could be
a possible
access method for it
and it could be that it is stored in the
data repository but like you know net
model pulls from the neural net
repository capability data might pull
from the you know some particular type
of
of data resource
but can we make sure that that's in the
goal project list please although to the
extent that we have you know string
completions right i mean couldn't
couldn't we kick query code assist i
mean we'd need to know
how to access that but right presumably
there's some way to access that the list
that i know we really want what i really
want
is a
you know
i want a um
a data set of this and i would even like
to embellish this a bit by having some
more human readable names for these you
know i want to make a table based on
these and maybe these capital letters
are fine
but
i mean it's just lots of places i mean
my favorite example of this is sound
note
where
why is this so slow you saw how slow
that was john
oh it's a bit difficult to tell over
zoom okay well i'm gonna i'm gonna do
something and then i'm gonna let you
know how slow it is okay
so um
that's it okay that was typing really
slowly and now i'm gonna hit re hit
return now
that was really slow
so i'll tell you my observation when my
session is older this is slower
is there any way anything you'd like me
to look at because this is a big old
session is there anything you'd like me
to look at that would tell you i mean
okay there's an untitled 14 there which
gives you some indication but but is
there a way to know how much front-end
memory is in use
um
yeah but i
have to
i have to look it up i don't remember
type count of dollar front end
yes
really
is that documented i don't think that's
documented
it's been there since
version three it is documented
it is documented
wow it looks like it was added in six
oh it is right there in in the main
usage no less
that reminds me of something i've been
meaning to tell somebody about and i i'm
just i'm going to use this excuse to do
it um
uh
because i hope avery or somebody else
can take these notes text
has some alternate use cases with
offsets
and rotation and i
didn't even know it had that and they
should be up in this section
did you understand i got that
okay
um
that presumably goes to press
yeah you could probably compare to
insect because it's it's pre i think it
follows pretty closely with what inset
does
okay
um
anyway i want to come back to sound note
for a second
oh my god this is so slow i'm typing
this is not echoing my typing
okay i hit that now
and it only just came up
so there's anything else you'd like me
to do john to debug this i mean my front
end is at 3.5 gigabytes now which is
awesome
yeah yeah well i um
my
my guess is that we have some
internal hash tables uh
that are
that are getting too large for their
britches and
need to be cleaned out um okay
so
um i don't i don't have anything else
for you to try but
uh
i'll
i'll i'll start investigating but i i
don't i don't want to try to divert
anything now i don't have anything quick
and easy for you to look at that fine
well actually i do have one thing quick
and easy but it'll take me a second to
look it up so
but like this is so freaking annoying so
here for example
i want these names
and i want a human name you know rock
space organ for example
or you know some other human name for
these things see what i'm saying so i
can make a table
of you know this is the waveform for
this and that nailer
right well
yeah but that i will point out that is
neither a programmatic nor a
data scraping project right that's a
human curation problem i know it's got
some human curation we have to do some
actual work but but the zeroth order
piece of this is to make a data set that
just has one column that's just these
things
um
anyway
and by the way if i look at
font variations
i pres oh god this is driving me crazy
the speed
you know you can just down arrow and hit
enter to accept that
completion yeah i understand that but
i'm that's not the issue if i accept i
understand but you can you can avoid the
immediate annoyance by only typing in
you know five characters and then down
arrow instead of all 15. oh okay i'm
just practicing my typing
okay
so these are the only ones there are no
others ever allowed
there well there are
more but they're not documented because
they like i said they may only apply to
certain characters of certain fonts of
certain platforms what's an example
uh
we'd need ian for that
for example
yeah certain like yeah ligatures
or the numerals where the
you know the baseline is different
type things
where nine has a descender
to be honest to find jeremy by any
chance oh jeremy d
no
not yet
okay
um
what does underlight do
oh uh under light is what gives uh uh
spell checking
it's uh you know uh
you can give it a color
it's not boolean
right and you would presume okay
and we're going to be improving it to
add some
some styles uh
some different kinds of underlighting
and and other uh
forms of control in thirteen one
so wait a minute so let's see what's a
shadow
that
is one that i'm not sure will even
work
okay something
can you blow that up because i can't see
what it actually did
all right
it's weird
okay so then we have so we're actually
working on a more robust uh uh
controllable and platform uh independent
version of that for 13.1 we were asked
to do it to help for example uh
you know being able to plop labels onto
uh maps and that sort of thing
ah
they they they are shadowed with a
transparent
i don't know what it is something which
makes them stand out over the background
by by
usually a contrasting color so that i
mean like your mouse cursor is
yes
and so u2 is working on a pixel shader
method uh which we can use to create
some very general sorts of effects with
a lot of levers of control
okay that's cool
all right so the question is
should these be like underlined
which by the way the fact that this says
underline and the function is called
underlines still freaking weird
okay what does if i do well right it's a
different sense one is a boolean flag
the other is a style name it's not look
at that
right i i don't think that's actually
inconsistent
fair enough
and so neither shadow nor outline work
under windows
um
okay which is which is because we're
just using what the operating system
gives to us and
macintosh gives us the stuff windows
doesn't
okay
but like the leg some of the ligatures
only work on windows and not mac or
linux or or maybe even only on some
fonts right
the
we're adding for 13.1 we're adding the
ability to
uh
to control various open type features
which it controls things like ligatures
things like uh uh the reason ian added
it was because he was annoyed
uh for uh by the kind of zero you know
he didn't like the zero with the dot he
wanted zero with the slash
and that's that's an open type feature
um i mean feature you mean you can tweak
the fonts somehow right
individual fonts will have uh
choices in them uh that you know whether
or not to do a given ligature or whether
or not numbers are old style or or
conventional uh
uh that sort of thing um
whether or not zeros have dots slashes
or nothing uh
so
uh you know not every font has every
feature uh but uh but it's a thing that
fonts offer which
you know it's uh it's kind of it's a bit
power user to be able to get to those
things but it's very nice to be able to
do so
if that's what you want okay all right
so
let's look at these
um
i think this underlight thing is a
useful thing and i wonder whether that
can be
so what we've got
um so we've got underlined which i
didn't know existed
yep um
and we could imagine a general
you know font
well at the top by the point where the
general font something i'm like why are
we not just using
font variations
as an option
yes
you mean what we have right now yes
right
the idea right the advantage of of
having these named styles is that you
can just say
style of foo comma
underlined yeah as opposed to foo comma
font variations goes to underline goes
to true
um
i think jeremy just the other jeremy
just joined her hello
hi we're talking about uh supporting
of font
variations um more directly in the
language
okay
um
and
uh
okay so i mean like for example
underlighted let's say we had
underlighted of red but maybe we could
also have underlighted of some you know
maybe we could just have underlighted
like that
um
be some automatic underlighting yeah
yeah
right look at the default to the red
that we use for spell check say
or something different right but okay so
that that's that one
um
strikethrough
i just it feels so much like an action
you know be like strikethrough
of the steps
well i was going to say the analogy with
underlined would be stricken through
struck through or struck through
this is horrible
stricken we'll we'll be using wence
pretty soon
we should have that you know as a way to
get some kind of trace back
you know i still use shown rather than
shined so you know
tells you where i where i learned my
english
i don't actually no i can't decode that
actually but but okay well
you know just in terms of this you know
uh uh tense you know verb tense thing uh
something else to consider is that
uh
we have the
option
frame
and the head
framed
i know
yes
so this is more like
i mean
bold could be bolded but it isn't
right
yeah maybe
right i was going to say in some sense
underlined is the
wrong one
although it's consistent with right like
dashed right
although we have both dashed and dashing
of
right or you know dashed and dashing so
okay so that's another one the ing
right because we could have
i mean we could have
under lighting which is maybe what you
had elsewhere to be the to be the form
that takes eat something
get what i'm saying
i mean the consistent thing would
probably be bold
underline under lighting
now unfortunately lighting is an option
we also have highlighted
uh yeah although that's kind of a weird
thing right
i don't know how weird it is
that's weird
uh
i know right it's it's like i took you
know i i opened up my desk drawer took
out the highlighter and and drew on my
monitor
that's just
i mean i guess it's not that weird but
it's much better doing it virtually than
physically
i mean is it obvious that we don't want
something called underlighted as well as
highlighted
well can you underlight a general
expression i don't see why not john
well
it
so what will happen if you underlight a
graphic
you got a little wiggly line underneath
it
yeah
what happens if you do like a fraction
does the numerator and denominator get
squiggles independent uh
for now yes that would be the case
i think that's just fine
i mean
honestly this seems like a
a thing that would be quite useful i
mean i i don't use this as much as i
would like to i used it more i think
when it first came out
i should remember it i mean i use
um
i i think underlighted as a function
would be useful
now things like strikethrough
see these things are very weird to me as
font variations i mean i understand that
technically they're font variations but
they just feel like you know striking
strikethrough what just doesn't seem
like a thing that would be a font
variation
except it's right if op write the what
is it the command t is that what opens
the the font dialog right those are all
options that appear in
in standard font dialogues right
i mean people understand these as font
variations
irrespective of the technical details
do they
i think so
some people at least
um
right so they're okay so on my linux
desktop they're called effects
uh
strikeout underlying
but people have only thought about
applying them to fonty type things
i mean exactly and that's well i mean
i think that's generally true right bold
it doesn't make your your lines any
thicker it'll affect
the the texty things inside of whatever
expression
as would you know italic
but underlighted doesn't underlight it
is potentially a more global effect
well that's i underlighted the head
that's not unrelated the style i don't
think no i
that's probably correct
okay but but now let's look at these
other ones strike through what's the the
use case for strikethrough
you see what i can imagine is somebody
wanting to say you know map i mean i do
this all the time you know map framed
onto
range of 10 or something all the time i
do that
could do that same thing with
highlighted
i
um i mean the question is with
strikethrough
is it the same story
or is strikethrough something that is
really a thing no it's an it's a named
style
i i know that that's the case right now
but i'm saying
in
if
if we had the capability like like for
example here
you know
it's it's rather useful that i could
just say highlighted here
okay
i would question that that's useful but
fine um
well i i mean you know it would be
like well i mean a trivial example would
be uh
you know visualizing uh
what do they call it the the the net of
primes you know you're you're taking
integers and yeah it's right um
so you know and any place where you have
a list of things and you're wanting to
call out specific elements or in the
case of strikethrough it might be things
that have you know things that are not
relevant for example
see if if prime q highlighted this is
lovely i mean
else identity
you need the pure you need
my god i'm really i'm really
losing it i'm that that's if
if bubba but my gosh what am i doing
here
highlighted a pound and then just pound
rather than yes yes yes yes and
yeah i don't know why you deleted the
ampersand
okay lovely
um
right
right and i i suppose you could make the
the second pound
you know style of pound font variation
goes to strikethrough
yeah yeah
i mean i'm kind of wondering whether
whether it is of interest
to give a sub value to style
does this make any sense
to be equivalent to style x comma red it
could
it could um
the
does it need to round trip
or is this something that evaluates
yeah i really don't i really don't want
to round trip this i don't round trip it
it's stupid to round trip it it's
unnecessary to round trip it
and if you did style red comma 32 it
would still
continue out you know well of course the
problem is what happens to the style of
32 comma red
i think that's the end of my idea
yeah yeah
okay i was gonna say i'm just as likely
to do style of red 32
which of course would uh you know do its
own thing it would give you the 35 yeah
it would give you
right it would give you a little red box
at font size 32.
and now you can click on it and get a
color selector for your uh
but it didn't change the font size in
that
right okay all right so so anyway so
what what are the issues here so what
we're saying is
underlighted as a possible thing to
generalize highlighted
that's what i support for that
okay and i mean do do i guess the
question is do we feel like
strikethrough or
small caps all caps are sufficiently
useful to promote to style named styles
or do they just stick as font variations
when you say name styles you may not
symbols yes
okay let's go through each one and turn
okay
okay so strikethrough
what are the use cases
i mean
you you usually the big one is to
indicate things which are in a list that
should be considered
you know
being omitted for some reason
obsolete removed etc
the other thing about strikethrough is
that i can imagine you know strike
through its most simple-minded form it's
just the same color
you know just the font with its same
color struck through
but i can imagine like underlighted that
you know you might want to say it's
black but i want to strike through in
gray
for example
is that possible i mean obviously you
could do an overlay of of two things
yeah i mean that's that's what would
have to be is we would have to draw
synthesize our own strikethrough effect
which just seems fine to me i mean
unless fonts do fonts do anything
special with strikethrough
um the
i
fonts no the the font system i mean you
know we're basically using the font uh
uh rendering system in the operating
system and
you know it's going to decide how to
render the strikethrough but
no strikethrough isn't something that
i'm aware of that is a feature of the
font itself though
do you know how it positions the strike
uh
i i i i i
i was in fact stopping myself from
serving on and on that's that's the one
thing i could imagine that might be in
the font file is is the position of the
strike but i'm not sure if it is or if
it just gloms onto something else like
in like an axis line or something
i'm not sure it's a major use case for
us but strikethrough is a common font
variation that's used in chat clients i
don't know if it really
ties into our chat system as much but
what does it mean though
i mean it's a common system you know if
you're using slack or other things it
typically is one of the prominent font
variations next to bold and italics what
does what do people typically have it
mean though
i think it's probably context dependent
but often it's
again sort of providing information that
it's either what does it mean what does
it mean i i i i i would i would guess
that that at least some people are using
it in the same way that uh the plain
text people use carrot
right is what
right as a right as a joke right you
know
you you you use
right you you use
some archaic term that use for
archaic in whatever sense of archaic
and then you you know you have that
strike through and you replace it with
the you know
a modern term
or you know uh
isn't it fun what politicians stupid
strikeout actual name a politician did
you know
right okay so it's it's ironic in some
sense i mean it it's real use tends to
be in documents where you're showing
what's been deleted
exactly i was going to say they're
extremely useful step by step a lot
so again
yeah for step by step like you can't
this term with this term
oh interesting
why do you put strike through through
that
because you want to get rid of them in
the next line
so you're doing a strikethrough on a a
piece of mac a divided by a you strike
through both this one
how do you draw that strike through
as a standard textual strikethrough yeah
using this font variations mechanism
yeah
and it works on so i mean if i say i'm
not saying we do it in alpha but people
do it you see it oh i see i see i see i
see exchange and related things
okay
that is not beautiful
what would you do well
michael what would you do here if you
had a you know if you if you could do
whatever
the diagonal one would be looking much
nicer
right but that's not a font variation by
the way aren't these font things gray or
am i misreading that uh
i
suspect that yeah yeah it looks like
they are
um
i noticed to jeremy's point
that it has somehow avoided the
you know i think that's a weird thing
with the plus sign i think it's the
midpoint of the x height is my guess but
i don't know how that works with that
plus sign
right and
you know you may get a different result
like if if you change x plus one with
the string containing x plus one you may
get a different result yeah well let's
let's just say um
uh
help me out here somebody
one
10 i think
i want to get some of the funky ones
um
wow
weirdness abounds
what the heck
is that to do with our rendering of
these things
um
the
i mean it certainly is the case that
those characters are being rendered in a
different font by us
um
so
yeah it's it's probably because the
fonts
um
whatever line is drawing the
strikethrough on is just different
between the two fonts
i see just saying
relative to the baseline
okay
okay
so
you know what michael is
reporting is that a generalized
strikethrough
which would to me be like kind of the
analog of filling and graphics or you
know whatever else
is um
you know i still have not used it
anything i've written i still have not
used any of our nice new graphic
spelling stuff i have to find a place to
use that
a similar version would be you're having
a failman slash
so a little bit more diagonal than
normal and a little bit longer
i thought it was a dirac slash
much as it's a
little
no it's direct i'm sure okay from the
black equation
yeah um
the anyway the the um but yes
a slashed character right
i mean so
okay
to me strike through as okay as a font
variation it's fine but i think it's
somewhat limited and i think it would be
interesting to have a strikethrough that
was capable of dealing with a situation
like this in a not totally stupid way
um
our sound on our livestream is
commenting that strikethrough can be
abused to get h-bar
um yes that's another another or you
could just use the character h-bar
indeed
um
but uh but you can't use i mean p-slash
and so on for momentum
with a
yes
with your your game
right
a nice scour matrix
uh dressed in a goal matrix i suppose
yes um adorned with okay in any case all
right so look it seems to me let's go
back and think through a possibility for
a strikethrough function
um
that is i mean i wish it was past tense
like underlighted could be
um but i think that's where we should go
with that
let's talk about the small caps thing
okay because that's the other one you
have listed here and i think what was
the other one that we had down here
uh small caps and all caps
okay and there's also the shadow
business which i think is sort of
well and there we're going to we're
going to say more about shadow
in probably the next month or so you're
we're going to come back around to this
shadow business okay fine
fairly different approach
okay all right so then then let's talk
about um
uh
the caps business
um
i wish i had a good place to put these
maybe i should just have one maybe i
should have an ild look i do and i have
it do i have an lcc no i don't how many
years have we been doing lcc meetings
uh five or six
well now we have a folder for them
which perhaps we can remember okay all
right all caps small caps
okay let me let me understand something
here so if i say oops
here's one that i needed to do right
recently very recently like yesterday
actually
um
let's see what this actually worked for
me and i didn't know how to do this
uh
the extra bracket i know
what do you know
right then presumably if if the first a
had been a
a
lower
all be the same size
yeah now now this we actually this we
synthesize uh this does not come from
the operating system we're doing this
does that mean the kerning is wrong
uh
no
i mean i mean
well i mean basically what we're doing
is we're just uh
uh creating a smaller version of the
font
for the small caps
all right what is this like
as in
i mean
you know this to me is useful now what
does all caps do
and why aren't you just saying two
uppercase if you want all caps
well so it's a question of whether or
not you want to change the underlying
data or not
right so for example uh
the
um
[Music]
you know various tables on the website
right they
you know in in certain in certain tables
it appears as all caps in other cases it
preserves the capitalization so you
store it once
with the canonical capitalization and
then you set in the css
yeah i realized that the css can do this
but
and and
and you could say who cares and
and i'm i'm not saying i care uh
you know we could leave that as a font
variation that's fine
right the people who need this have the
capability to do this
well like the small caps thing though
something i mean look if you want to
make it up a case you can say to
uppercase
in most of the things in our language
most things i can imagine i mean
basically
people using our language the evaluator
is typically around
are making sense
you can assume the evaluator exists
yeah
whereas small caps there's no way to do
that with the evaluator
so the i mean
you know the the one place where you
could run into trouble with that is
uh
and i'm
not
really arguing for this but i i just so
you fully understand the consequences uh
you know where you have structure uh
you know you have a bunch of strings
embedded in structure oh and by the way
some of those spring strings
aren't being displayed some of those
strings are inputs to functions and they
can't change
so this is wrong this is wrong
why isn't that capital psi
big
uh
because we don't have a general enough
version of capitalization but that that
will that will change though
it's we're doing a bunch of string
improvements and this is going to come
with that
so
right and so i guess small caps only
applies to ascii or because
for now i belie i'm not sure if it's
only ascii but it certainly has limits
but that that will change though
so
i think that small caps is like red and
gray and things like that
and could be
unlike bold i mean i could imagine maybe
even a symbol called small caps
is that obviously stupid
not to me i think it's i mean if we're
going to have a symbol i think this is
the symbol to have just like we have
you know
plain bold italic small caps is it's
just another one i think we should have
it i think it's useful
and um okay so we've got that
we've got
underlighted
strikethrough we're still studying
that make sense
okay any other comments on this on this
area with regard to the caps i'll point
out that some of the presentation
notebook styles
use maybe small caps certainly all caps
oh my gosh i hate the ones that do all
caps i always fix it
i i agree with you
so i i i i i'm sorry jeremy that that
you may feel that's a wonderful choice
uh and we'll agree to disagree
did you put that in there or did it no
that we we did a variation of styles and
some of these to have their you know you
want visual variation between all the
styles there but that it's one it's
locked in i understand that if you don't
like it
it's annoying to unlock it it's actually
it's easier
as i recall
i don't think is it that easy it's in
the style sheet you have to dig no no
there's a drop down for it i think
okay
well i mean i mean for any given cell
it's easy to do you just change it on
that cell but yeah
you know okay you don't have to make a
style you change
question uh for john is there anything
else you want me to do in debugging why
this front end is so slow uh it's uh i
might have something for you later but
right now you have my full attention in
this meeting so fine i guess i i my
multitasking abilities are somewhat
limited stephen i have a quick small cap
question could i
share my screen really quick yep i'll
just
so i think what we're doing is
john you're probably just shrinking the
font smaller font size that is exactly
correct but yes if you look at what
happens in photoshop you've got equal
weight for all the strokes you know for
all the characters and you can't get
that if you just shrink font size so i
don't know if there's some
some way you can bump up the weight and
try to adjust i don't know how this is
done but proper small caps is uniform
and and when you do it like this you
don't really get the same look
so
um
until recently the answer
would have been just a definite no under
windows and i you know i think on
macintosh it's more possible but uh
uh
i i
not sure if we have i don't think we
have a smooth slider control on the
weights we uh
but we do have
but you know like under windows it was
until
at 12 30 i think it was uh it was like
you might remember we were trying to get
semi-bold in there and weren't able to
do it until 12 or 12 3. um
this is more subtle than semibolt this
is not a proper weight this is like a
faux bolding i think happening here
yeah um
i
i i don't know how to do this to be
honest
it's probably not a killer but just
something to be aware of if we really
want to
do it properly
i don't know what's involved in this
project again it's
it's i'm sorry
i said it's ian's project
not quite en isn't really looking into
something quite like this
no i think it is
i mean because small caps are you know
some of those things that like ligatures
and whatnot
all right let's move on i i think we
that point is making small caps look a
bit less attractive but i still think
it's a useful thing to have
all right can we can we go on to this
place yes yeah um
column decides that typeset term other
included context
so sorry i haven't written up a proper
reference page for this yet um although
i don't think it'll be hard
but
my notion was that we would just have an
alighted context function
it's our option excuse me uh
a front end option that could be applied
on a given cell or whatever
and
it could have a list of explicit
contexts or you could just pass it all
and
in those cases the underlying cell
expression would still have the full
context it would evaluate properly it
would save properly it would copy
properly
but it would just display as something
different
well that would be good
um
it would display something different and
and it would just have you know like one
cursor movement over
the thing you know the alighted portion
so it's it
in a way you can it's it's kind of like
the uh coding ligatures you know the
uh that we've
called them operator appearances but the
coding ligatures in a way it's kind of
like that
um
uh except it's not something that uh
cursoring through would uh
uh would break it apart yeah
so what did you have in mind for the
actual look
i
i don't know
i think it should be some boxed object
so
so
i mean there are two general directions
we can go in
one is a uniform appearance regardless
of uh context and the second is some
variation based on you know if you have
two or three or four different contacts
inside a given expression yeah we could
do something like we do for cryptography
where we have a color-coded you know
where we have you know when if you do
um
right so so
you know you won't have any idea what
the context is but you'll be able to
tell if these two assuming there aren't
too many contexts you'll be able to tell
if these two symbols are in the same
context or a different context
uh or or you can provide some you know
maybe there's some way you can you know
embed a bit of information like for
example how many context markers are
there and would that somehow have a
predictable effect on the appearance or
just first letter last letter
i mean look the main thing is we want a
single character size
object
yeah and i would love to integrate the
backtick into that object
you know just a a
you know something more integrated like
that you know like the thing i've now
got with the highlight there
okay so so you would not want to have a
separate backtick character i don't know
what is it i don't i think it's just
very noisy i mean jeremy do you have a
comment on that
we still have jeremy davis yeah i'm here
i don't really have a strong opinion
though
how does this even look much better
without the explicit tactics
i was going to say my two preferences
would be just a backtick and nothing
no we can't do that because that means
something different
yes it does a pure backtick is a local
is a sub context
well i mean it's going to look like that
sure but you know in context of like
information or something
i'm wondering if we want just sort of a
some sort of stylized context symbol
like maybe it's grayer or yeah that's
what i like
i think the whole thing should be look i
like the idea of some kind of visual
clue about whether things are in
different contexts i think that's a
clever idea
and i think color a muted color would be
a decent way to do it
by the way another option which we
haven't discussed is that we could uh
apply some sort of styling uh to the
entire symbol
yes
that might give a clue as to the nature
of the hidden context
well i'm not sure we want the nature i
mean i'm thinking that if a symbol is
grade for example that would be a
reasonable way to indicate
that it's a foreign symbol of some kind
but i think we need something in front
of it i think we need a little mark in
front of it
and then maybe the symbol gets slightly
grayed down or maybe i think we need to
try this we need a design for the mark
and i would recommend that the mark has
some blob of color dan
on our live stream is suggesting uh
perhaps
in context aliasing that one could have
some capability to specify
what the allied version of that context
could be
in a mechanism like context daily asking
that make sense
uh
context aliasing is a
firmly a concept that lives firmly in
the kernel
um i see well okay but i mean whereas
here we're really talking about
something that was firmly in the front
end well i know that but i mean the
context aliasing
is basically a mapping between contexts
and between aliases and contexts and
here a lighted context could be a
mapping between contexts and uh light
illusion the lighted forms
yeah
so john would you ever see the
the lighted contacts
like the illusion part of it in an input
cell
my thinking
although i'm happy to discuss this but
my thinking is that if you were to copy
this say out of an information cell
and paste it into an input cell that it
would just all expand out
sadly i think that's what it has
certainly an input form seller has to do
that
but
i think it'd be great if it didn't
expand out and maybe look clearly when
you mouse over it it should show you
what the full context is perhaps when
you click it it expands itself out
i just don't think you want the expanded
form most of the time
well i think okay so my opinion is when
you're looking at it in information most
of the time
you you don't need the context there are
a few cases but
mostly you don't but if you copy it into
an input cell
correctly you're more corrected it needs
to be there probably because you're not
going to copy a giant
well right because i right you know
right because say i'm debugging my
function and i want to figure out why
you know this down value isn't firing
right so i copy out the down value i
paste it into an input cell and then i
you know give it the input and
right and i need all those other things
to be in the right context
and the fact that it blew up a little
bit isn't so bad because you know i just
have the one down value
tan is suggesting that
without the horrifying general utilities
which by the way is something i so much
want to get rid of
what did this just do it created a
notebook yeah it's
uh
it's a thing
it's a telly thing
yeah
right and then you can click on that and
it'll open another notebook with more
definitions rather nice
another good idea from tally
why haven't we done anything with this
well you know it's
uh
i mean it's the underline here
is the indicator that it's a special
type of thing right
is that correct
uh natural
well i suspect so
well that's a good
thank you for that comment
so i mean the real potential problem
here is
window vomit uh
by which we don't want windows we don't
want it to bring up yeah i'm not yeah
i'm not suggesting the separate window
thing i'm suggesting uh
but uh but but that sort of thing could
maybe be
uh
uh encapsulated into attached cells or
something but it could also be an
information
i mean that could be the output in
question mark whatever
reasonably small functions but it
doesn't scale
i think we've agreed here special
character here i like the idea of a
color blob
that's a hash of the of the of the
context
i think this aligned contexts
the reason i don't like that name as
such
is that it suggests something more
functionality oriented than appearance
am i making sense
yeah i'm not
i'm not sure i i i understand why i mean
i understand what you're saying i'm not
sure i understand why you're saying that
because i think elided context might
mean oh
you're going to and people don't
understand what we will understand about
when's the parser running versus when's
the evaluator running and so on
can imagine people just thinking oh that
means it just ignores those
contexts um
i mean i'm thinking you know it's more
like context display or context
uh
well then it would be a boolean right i
mean you're only worried about the all
case which i mean is probably the most
common case well what about context
delusions
or
masked contexts
i like that one
i'm not sure i like masked ones
maybe it's because i see the
anyway the mask does a bad thing in a
pandemic you know
look good depending on how you look at
it but whatever
triply vaxxed contexts
um
context
i just don't like this this this really
seems like functionality not display
uh
i mean i think context deletions is fine
it sounds fine to me
um and you know
it it preserves
some capability that in addition to
i mean in that form it sounds like
we
don't know that we want to go to all the
trouble but if we ever did and wanted to
extend the syntax so you say this
context goes to
you know
some kind of religion you know
that names
sorry which name says
says that so
it does i'm i think we should go ahead
and implement this maybe we can
implement this context deletions but i
reserve the right to suggest a different
name
okay
is there any time you don't reserve the
right to suggest a different name well i
mean i understand that i'm just warning
people that if you burn this in deeply
into the code
there's you know
um
it's easy
easier than i'd like to admit to you for
me to change these names
okay and i like the idea of a color blob
and i think design should try and come
up with some thing for this with a
little
maybe a little dot of color inside it
like a little circle of color inside it
doesn't make any sense and i don't know
so it's going to be a hash so is it
going to be a like a small array with
color
no no no it would just be a single color
so what we would do is we would it would
because the the choice of color is
itself the hash okay all right
so basically you know it'd be one of the
you know be something like this and
and the question is if you have you know
in a typical expression you're going to
have i don't know two or three contacts
maybe and what this display kind of
encourages me in is the chance they're
going to be identical the color is going
to be indistinguishable is low
that's what i'm saying
now if we if we make these a little bit
and and and i think i think some i think
there's a little bit of work out there
with
with the notion of color hashing to try
to you know ensure that different values
produce different
or visually distinctive colors i can
i i can i can look up that i think
people have done some work on that
before but there doesn't make shape into
it
yes
circles and diamonds and small stars
i mean by the way this is not the first
time the notion of a color hash has come
up uh in you know that i've been
involved in a discussion about color
hashing so yeah it'd be nice to have a
function and function positive for that
i i think there is
yeah i think we discussed something like
this about a year ago internally for i
don't remember the context but uh
yeah but it wasn't about context that's
all we know no
[Laughter]
um
you see is there a color hash function
oh
that's something called hash you
yeah there you go
i don't know whether it doesn't think
profound but
i mean it probably creates the hash
you know divides it by the maximum
number for that and
feeds it to hue
you know i literally just yesterday did
a thing where i should have used this i
i just literally hashed values and
looked at the numbers
um in any case i mean you know the main
thing i'd want to avoid is an algorithm
which is likely to
you know produce uh a nearly black
version of blue and a nearly black
version of red and and and you know
think that they're
distinctive you know yeah right i
understand but so i i think the random
color together with i mean as a first
cut random color with a lightning like
this and a dot of that would be pretty
reasonable because i think you're going
to see many copies of you know what
you're going to see is an expression
with many of the blues and many of the
cyans or something
something yeah and and i think it's very
unlikely that you get i mean it's
possible that you have many of this many
of this but okay you could have those
two science i don't know we should try
it but i think something like this is
going to be good and the concept of
shape based one is reasonable as well
that's up to jeremy and the design team
whether we can fit that kind of
information in there okay okay
all right
this is formal operators oh my god what
a mess
you know i find myself using this wfr
function unformalized symbols all the
time
because when i want to display things
i typically want the unformalized
version
but
yeah well we're gonna have to update it
because it's there's a lot of formal
stuff in the pipeline
yeah okay well let's take a look
right so i mean i don't know if you read
through my little summary there but uh i
just read it yeah i mean
right so
just to give right so
um
right i spent like you know
between 10 and maybe 60 seconds thinking
of the names for uh
all of these so the the names haven't
been carefully curated but right i went
through and picked these things and then
there are those questions we'll need to
answer
okay so the basic idea here is
if we pick
if we look at for example
okay so right now we have the situation
with axiomatic theory okay that if we
say
even boolean axioms
okay what we're using is
circle plus circle times to represent
what are really uh and in or
okay
and it's kind of somebody has a weird
piece of interference on the phone i
don't know what that is
um
sounds like an old-fashioned
uh modem
that's interesting
maybe you're not hearing it maybe i'm
not hearing it i i am hearing it yes it
is it's very quiet but it's there yes it
could be like a line printer or
something yes
um
okay in any case
so
the concept for this is what
i mean is the concept that for example
if i do the ones for ring theory
that instead of using i mean we've got a
bunch of weird weird funkiness here
you know we've got the the
that weird little thing that's got kind
of like a
cyclops with a hat on it type thing
right that's that should be a dotted
zero probably
just making sense i mean that's the zero
that's the identity for addition
okay comment on this i mean maybe this
one isn't too bad because it's these
circle operators are okay but this is
suggesting
additional forms of plusing and timesing
and so on
right because the complaint was you
didn't have enough pluses and times for
you know
all the axiom systems so
yes so the conclusion was all right well
let's add a bunch of pluses and times
and if we also need some
n's and ors i'm sure i could find some
n's and ors to add to this list you know
like a dotted and or dotted or
or some such so you could have uh
you know
yeah i mean these are all amusing and i
mean they're definitely not bad
does michael have a comment or anybody
else on where this is going
i think they look useful
okay
so my comment here is that i think we
had two
uh different discussions at the same
time there was the discussion of the
formal operators and there there was the
discussion of the need of more operators
and
i think
both things are
interesting so so it's good to have all
these operators so that we can have more
and more complicated theories and then
there was the thing that what happens if
the user is already using some of these
symbols we are going to spoil
that and that's where
formal versions of these
user usable operators
could also
be there
right but i think this is instead of
more
formal things yeah i think so too i
think and we've got
plus dot with another dot and it's
yeah everybody's going to go dotty
right and and if we're worried about
user symbols we could make the these
these new symbols protected and switched
to using those and then
you know except for malicious users who
unprotect the symbols
we you know will be fine
no no no i think i think the point here
is that in the same way that we have a
which is usable by the user and then
format a which is protected we have
circle plus which is usable by the user
and then if anything we we could have a
format circle plus what we should never
have is a formal class
that's my point
sorry so again a formal is a formal
circle plus we could have but not a
formal plus why
exactly because i think
what we need formal is for
is to use symbols that could be used
already by the user
we don't know why
because plus
your claim is
that plus the formal formalization
is a way to say this isn't going to be
uh you know you can't set a value for
this
plus you wouldn't want to set a value
for any way
except as opposed to this is a variation
on plus to indicate that it means
something slightly different exactly
well i mean
right but do
do we need a formal plus if we have you
know plus hat and plus dot and
all of those guys no that's that's the
point i'll say is make exactly
it's a different question
well i think it can't hurt to have these
extra symbols i would not protect them
i think by the time somebody is
going to that much trouble to blow
themselves up they should blow
themselves up
um i wanted to say for axiomatic theory
two things that we really need
one is a
common name for these
these axiom systems for making tables of
them the other is which occurs to me
is that we could always have
um
some kind of association that is just
like we can say for this
something like operators
right that there
that's essentially a mapping
that gives you the
meaning although it's not really quite
the right way round and we could perhaps
have another one that is the right way
round that is the substitution you make
to turn this into
a thing which is actually semantically
understandable immediately
does that make sense
and what i could imagine
is something where you can have
something which deformalizes
in a table like this or you have an
association
that has something like
you know
etc
that crazy
see the point i mean
it's just a way to if you want to make
the unformal version
i was actually thinking about whether
you should be able to do that using the
font variation sort of thing that we
were talking about first where
it's still formal a but
you set this style and it renders
without the dot that's very interesting
that's a very interesting idea
i mean in traditional form it could
render without the dot
which it doesn't right now right
it always renders with the dot
that's a very interesting idea that we
could hide the css style in font
variation is that plausible
implementable guys
it is implementable
right i mean we're basically just
imagine you know draw adding the dot on
our own so we just need the style that
says don't don't bother drawing the dot
casual
yeah
uh remove formal wear
don't
or or you could use informal if
you know casual's too casual
um i think that's a really good idea
because that would save i mean a lot of
issues that i've run into using this
stuff
it's nice to have these
axioms with the formal symbols
i mean it might be super confusing
maybe traditional form would switch off
the dots which i think would be good
let's investigate having traditional
forms switch off the dots
anybody want to comment on that jose
michael anybody else
i i mean so once we have the option
right it's just adding the option to the
traditional form style definitions and i
mean that seems reasonable to me
okay but i want to know from michael and
jose whether they think it's super
confusing i think there may be some
people like paul ebber to do everything
in traditional form we will not like it
we for instance also do all that input
in traditional form like is the dot in
the input traditional form visible or
not
yeah i see some people complaining
if there is
no clear distinction between
formal a and a
well but traditional former lies many
things
you know that there are many things that
are
like a
you know i don't know a vessel function
it's just a j in in in traditional form
uh
although the i suppose the point is that
you could
you know at least there there's the
tooltip that tells you it's it's well we
could have tooltips here
look the fact is in using this stuff a
big pain point has been
having to say unformalized symbols all
the time but it would be only in
traditional form output not in
traditional form input
i guess that's right okay
is that doable
i suppose that should be doable
yeah
it's
not as happy as i would like it it might
involve throwing a dynamic on the right
hand side of that option
well okay
let us investigate that possibility in
terms of these additional things
um we're gonna need to spend a few more
minutes actually understanding you know
based on the unicode description and
things
whether
you know whether these names are right
they look they don't look far off
is is underbar what we call another bar
i think so
it's another bar with a capital b
right
and overdoses is a capital d as well
are you sure about that i thought i
actually checked overbought
under bar definitely is
okay so all right so the symbol name
is
yeah over dot is capital d yeah all
right okay i was just confused
okay
um
so i assume when we have under do we
have under tilde
as a symbol you mean yeah we do not
but we do have over tilde
what is this weird you know
1980s 1970s
computer noise
okay well okay so the question here
we have to be a little bit careful
reading through these things to make
sure that there is no
possibility
that we want to take over these things i
mean like plus till plus tilde is sort
of okay
and why did you choose these particular
ones
uh
these are existing unicode symbols that
we have not given long names to that
right but these are the only unicode
symbols available in this general
semantic space is that right or
uh are these the on i'm
i'm not sure these are the only ones but
these are the ones that seem to be in
the general spirit of having more
you know more more operators for you
know
ring theory with you know three
different times and fine
and and and all these symbols have been
in unicode for a long time right i think
i think i think these all date the
version two certainly the overwhelming
majority date
yeah i would agree with that
okay i don't have any obvious objection
to these
all right and then
the plus and time ones are flat and then
the
not sure about the down semi-direct
press
who's saying they're flat no no no don't
make them flat
that's going to kill a bunch of operator
stuff for
poor axiomatic theory okay well then are
they left associative or right
associative
thinking
oh
gosh
let me ponder that question does anybody
does anybody else have an opinion about
this
i think it will depend on every single
one
well do you think you can pick it for
under tilde plus
i mean that was a surprise when i was
doing this stuff for version three
i looked through a lot of books and i
found that the precedence was surprising
what about the precedence of these
things what about the precedence well
yeah that's that's another thing that
needs to be figured out you're saying
they're plus like in their times like
right well i you know by plus i can time
times like i meant more visual
appearance
yeah but they could also be
but yes in terms of uh of presidents
they you know could be in the general
vicinity of
plus and times yeah but i mean you know
circle times hat
versus square dot
what's the relative precedence
right well i i guess i don't have a
strong opinion on that
um
as i say i was very surprised when i
looked at this in the 1990s
um at how consistent books were and
there appeared to be a slight
correlation because they used a little
bit more space usually around lower
precedence operators
i mean we spent a lot of effort in
version three getting the precedence of
the circle times of this world right
and they have been surprisingly decent
well with the exception
of i'll show you one that i don't like
at all so d
what's that partial d
yeah partial d is wrong
what's wrong with it
two y
yeah
you need a subscript on it right
that looks okay
um
you know uh put put it put a put a five
in front of the x
oh for god's [ __ ]
this is what i've been saying for many
many years
that is totally not obvious
i'm totally wrong
wow how come i've never run into this
before
it's presumably unfixable at this point
is that true i mean where is it in the
precedence table
um
[Music]
well obviously above times
um
trying to remember
well i can see why it might be above
times because
if you imagine
you know
dx something or other times d y
something or other
you don't want it to be you know what
this is annoying but i don't think it's
wrong
okay was that i mean we would tell the
students that they really need to put
parentheses there to about the ambiguity
yeah i mean because otherwise
this look
well i i don't i don't think that's true
if it were f of x g of x then we might
but i don't think if for two f of x that
uh we would tell students they have to
include parentheses everybody would just
look at this case here
this case here is very nice that it
works
without any weird parentheses
and if you had
d being
uh lower precedence sometimes it
wouldn't work
so i don't think we got this wrong
i don't think we'll go wrong but now
okay these other things oh i was gonna
show you one that i don't like very much
okay going to go around
no i'm sorry i want to do it the other
way around fee
of wedge
yeah like this is a good example of
where i would like some kind of auto
parenthesization
or some ability to tell it to put parens
in there because i haven't a clue which
way around that pauses well that's what
multi-click is for
yes
i know i use it for that yes i
understand that but if you write it in a
document people don't get to multi-click
your piece of paper
okay
um
i mean i'd like something like this
where there's a way of putting
parenthesization in here
and this is in the in the general bucket
of finer control of a traditional form
which i'd like us to discuss at some
point
but okay for right now precedence tables
for all these things oh boy what a mess
dan on a live stream is suggesting why
not have a function that creates
formal operators that the problem with
that is that
that it's so hard for a person to get
that right and to get something that's
consistent
i mean we do have a precedence form
function which people almost never use
which hooks into the internal precedence
system
and has issues that you know i i
you know
in my copious free time i have attempted
to fix and you know the full request i
think has been stalled for like 2.5
years so
why
because because it's hard
oh i see it okay
and and then they require and it
requires you know it requires me to
you know working uninterrupted you know
without interruption for some period of
time so
right
um
so certainly do we really need to choose
different precedences not having them
all equal so that
parentheses yeah i think they should all
be equal of these buckets they should
all be equal and possibly they should be
equal to plus in times
so should it be plus in times or
circle plus and circle times maybe
better circle plus and circle times
what's the relative precedence of circle
person circle and plus
i
have to look that up
well whatever it is we can't tell
notice by the way that the type setting
has less space around the circle plus
than does around the main class
right so um
[Music]
right well i and then the the other
thing we would need to decide are
you know
which of these are flat which of these
are left associative and which are right
which are right associative
so circle times is tighter than times
circle plus is tighter than plus i think
that's okay
is it one step up from those or no
there's uh uh it's times then center dot
then circle times
um
yeah that is another one we got wrong
but that's a slightly different story uh
and then between plus uh there's uh
uh
sum and limit uh and
integrates
and then circle plus and minus but i'm
still exercised by the the um
associativity question
i mean
okay question is there a way to make it
always parenthesize
even if we
you know someone i'm saying that in
other words if we say something like
uh
if we have answers no
i'm saying i'm saying
in this case
oops oh uh mr kama
okay so now why did that parenthesize
because you you're going against natural
oh because because you're not you've
explicitly
nested something that's flat right so
that's distinguishing it from
the
difficulty of abc
okay it didn't auto flatten
correct
so it's parsing flat but it's not
evaluation flat
correct
that's fine then these operators should
be parsing flat just not evaluation flat
okay because that way when groupings
generates them and so on it'll it'll
just if it's binary if you want it in
binary form it'll do it in binary form
if you don't want it if you make a thing
that isn't binary it'll make it not you
know
so so i think i i think there are
obviously a couple of exceptions to this
right like circle divide divide doesn't
parse flat
yeah
um
so it should and and like the left
semi-direct and write semi-direct times
uh
what should they
do um
[Music]
well that just requires a moment of
thought about how yes it works
okay we should probably wrap up for
today but i think that seems like a good
conclusion so flat parsing not flat for
evaluation except in special cases
they would have
a a times block and a plus block
yep which would just join circle times
and
plus times and then i don't know about
the the semi-direct product
guys
have to look it up i don't know i'm sure
from what i did in the 90s i'm certain
that they have a
a
well-defined
precedence okay
um
all right anything else
then we've got
more things for next time
so
by the way i yeah in a previous meeting
we encountered the difficulty
of timing not properly going to parallel
threads
but that's another thing that should be
an lcc agenda at some point
well i mean i i don't think it was doing
anything wrong there right it was it was
doing exactly what you told it to do
yeah i know
but
anyway
okay anything else all right thanks guys
thanks to folks on live stream see you
another time
bye for now
bye